you
there we go you are playing join the
game I definitely want to join the game
wow I almost did not join the tournament
I created a terrible start a terrible
start okay
who knows you have to you have to get it
out of your system okay I'm not gonna go
in for that let's get a center Bishop c5
check let's throw this in first uh it's
hanging out of my knight play this g6
stop f5 I don't know how well my knight
is placed here I go 85 if beef maybe
maybe Bishop to a6 now get rid of their
light square Bishop this is my bad
Bishop they wouldn't give up the Queen
would they let's not do that just yet
it's gained a temple against the Queen
well at the end of the day they might
end up just recapturing at the night
anyhow let's do this yeah I guess they
are gonna go for that let's drop back in
my night into e4 it's a weak square
they're gonna take it they have pressure
against DC 6 I don't think f5 would be a
good idea maybe they should cover e4 now
so I'm with in checking distance maybe a
fork against the Queen let's push this
pawn maybe push them again what's that
let's let's uh chase that Queen away off
her Queen trade why not I'll attack
against my king all right and let's just
go here stop g4 f5 stuff secure the
position and I have a passed pawn in
this pawn is hit let's go fast I have a
big time edge here let's just castle
clamp down on g3 they don't have any
time they're down on time back to
tournament who 20 28 minutes remain
alright c5 no I'm gonna go for something
different after this don't think that
I'm gonna go fishing every game that's
not happening alright I saw a shark I
saw a shark
- I saw sharken entered very late in
this tournament a GM killer and not a GM
killer just a GM Oh watch out for the
Sharks okay let's focus on this square
we're gonna trade a little bit are we
take you and I take that night they have
to take my night first now I'm gonna
want to a pawn I'm getting that III
Square it's a juicy square that III
square let's hit that Queen my Knight
wants to be there that was bad
let's go my knight is gonna be an animal
you might have to give that guy up get
up the exchange put pressure on that pun
and he's weak as well keep pressure
there I get to the half-open file
why not played b6 just so there's no
undermining stuff with the b4 they might
still go for it I get the file my queens
in a good position I have a la a flight
square I didn't realize they move there
I have a big time edge I guess babysit I
want to move my knight into this square
now that's very weakening move what I
should do is not this let's try
something else they don't have any time
though my knight is better placed there
back to tournament land there he is the
shark the shark
okay let's try d 4 D 4 and C 5 I don't
know how oops let's not do that
I don't know how fast a win you're gonna
get with this opening but let's kick him
out for that diagonal well I have my
knight in there and then play f5 soon
well if challenged I think b3 might be a
good move after taking here although no
they dropped this square there this pond
c3 let's get Castle d5 let's take here I
got to go a 5 myself although I'm
dropping this pawn I gotta babysit him
first
this is not good if they're night moves
I take their pawn on e5 it's over
protect this mmm I want to keep my pawn
here I'll take with hit this and I'm on
the Queen no they missed that those
discovered attacks back to tournament
land ten eight five five twenty five
minutes remain
we got some good ones here clearly 2747
twenty-four ten Hui four try for a quick
scholars mate watch out I've done that
before
keep you on your toes keep you on your
toes
I'll take that break that Center up
let's castle d3 94 all right I'm gonna
take me pile up on that night b5 is
probably a good move
let's take care get the bishop pair they
have a they have a really strong Bishop
this is a weak point I gotta babysit
that guy there Bishop is beastly mmm
this is a very ugly move but I wanted to
stop Knight f4 at least for the moment
can my queen over here okay they're
gonna still go in here with their Knight
Queen trait I'm fine with I get to cover
this square that'd be nice
I do get to cover that square I'm gonna
try something like this mmm let's print
that night maybe they'll get scared
these pawns unprotected let's go back
change of plans
okay okay if I take this Bishop sticks
exposed if they took with their a pawn
not quite sure what I'm doing
let's get my Bishop over here to get my
King towards the center I think I could
push that night actually let's do it
right now a nice pandu oh okay with
giving up my light square bishop really
they're like scrap bishops gonna be an
animal I take that Bishop to b5 would
have been good their knight could hurt
me any moment
any moment huh
this could be really bad okay not
anymore
I think the worst is past oh that rook
has something to say about that though
my paw is dangerous dangerous pon
opposite color Bishop's give a check in
here okay mm-hmm they're giving checks
keep running keep pushing no no no I'm
gonna take my rook how's the clock not
good Oh so Ted's oh man man man man
opposite color bishops the Ferrari he's
gonna run right over me oh yeah this
guy's quick there's no there's uh what
am I trying to say I could do this first
there's no doubt no denying that the
Ferrari is fast okay let's get that
night in there Knight c4 Knight sea
floor is where I want to be Knight g4 I
shouldn't have allowed this why did I
allow that H file to open up this isn't
good huh trade light squared bishop I'll
take with my queen rook there's gonna be
played I thought at least yeah this
isn't good
not at all oh they dropped their rook
they forgot that my uh my knight was
doing what aisle blocking off the h4
square
this is back here move my knight
somewhere else take my knight oh they're
gonna give a check or are they they have
a time edge sum up a rook but it's a
pawn push soon on trade not the rook but
it it's it's a struggle man it's a
struggle this is the Ferrari I got a
check throw in a check what's their
Bishop up to no good no good keep that
up I'm floundering I just gotta take
stuff get their queen just take that out
oh they're flying they're definitely
flying I'm gonna be sneaky with their
pond oh wow are they fast oh it's a draw
the Ferrari was flying was up a rook and
that one too ah I shouldn't have given
up my rook like that at the end they had
that sneaky pond where I didn't know if
he was gonna move and I had to keep pre
moving I burned a lot of time because of
that sneaky pawn I shouldn't have let
him get into a sneaky position like that
you know what I'm talking about
am I making any sense oh okay let's get
expanding on the Queen side now let's
get a flight Square and e4 gonna happen
I get a pawn maybe I could go for sneak
attacks over here on h2 or not trading
ropes rooks and then Bishop to c6 might
have been better let's trade a little
bit I am up upon King towards the center
oh I had bishop here another opportunity
get freedom of that maybe
should have protected that pun let's
just double up though get to these uh
back rank rook trade okay see if I could
go a little bit faster kick that night
around he's close to being trapped isn't
he
pawn push I gotta watch out for Forks
okay let's box that night out stop him
from getting any activity throw that
night into pin okay he can't go anywhere
my rook is doing a good job you're doing
a good job right where you're at rook
okay now I could get in there and I
don't know here okay that was helpful
back to tournament oh that's the other
big thing is that you lose that streak
that very important streak was lost even
though it was a drawn you get some
points the shriek is gone okay let's go
in for this focus on an e5 push let's
take here and then focus on that d4
square okay got f5 let's grab some space
all right let's get this g4 break-in
actually maybe I want to do this trade
dark square Bishop s' hmm okay they're
getting that advanced in they're gonna
take my knight get a nice diagonal I'll
take the rook oh they're giving me their
dark squares this they don't have the
right palm break-in now with that last
move trade dark square Bishop s' okay
gonna trade Queens I get this Square and
get my knight on that Square this is
locked but not not enough I'm gonna push
that's welcome sight might have been
difficult actually to get
I'm making some active moves could take
that bishop maybe challenge that rook
maybe push this pawn even if it's
captured just to have something no just
to have some more open lines is what I
was gonna say offer a rook exchange
right look here rook to b3 they resigned
back to tournament 28 2018 18 there's a
big pack right around here and he's ten
point lead
he had a slip-up to Ferrari again hmm
slow down man okay so basically even if
you're up a rook you're gonna have a
problem against this guy noted
okay finally I stopped that advance that
h5 advance mm let's go here with maybe
b4 ideas let's try that and get this
advance in okay I wanted to go here but
Knight b3 let's try this what am I
missing I feel like I might be missing
something soon let's get back over here
Knight a fours happening soon I have a
second seventh oh that's painful
ouch that's painful
that's a fork and this is crumbling
mm-hmm I feel the pain I definitely feel
the pain oh it's crumbling fast I have
to go into another pin no no no no no
ten-second disadvantage and terrible
position not a good combination
oh how many Forks do you want to fall
for Oh what my first threat of the game
that was my first threat of the game Wow
good job your first threat of the game
you're gonna need that Bishop hang on to
him and that one too this is a crazy
crazy position
my queen was attacked I didn't see it I
have tricky nights but I don't have much
time
hit the bishop or the rook you don't
even know what pieces you have you don't
even know what pieces you have do you I
could have taken that rook I still could
have done tricky stuff oh boy get my
king towards the center um gotta go fast
a King and pawn ending how their time
wasn't taken down I could have sworn
they had less time I'm lucky to even get
out with a draw oh man takes your breath
right away these bullet games less than
half oh there's only 13 minutes left
let's hang onto him I wanted to actually
do something against their bishop stop
their Bishop from trading himself off
which he's clearly successful with right
now yeah I got way lucky to even get
away with the draw I should be thanking
my opponent for not mating me super
thank you for re for not beating me into
a pulp Knight takes g3 in the last move
and even in this game might be a
possibility you know I want to avoid the
draw I think there's a force draw if I
would have taken that night okay it's
the story with that cuz I'm getting that
night that pawn is pinned all right and
the Queen's are off Wow another bullet
dodged
okay the rooks are off they resigned
back to tournament that's another
another streak killer those drawers are
killers Ferrari
okay let's go with efore Knight to f3 if
I could move there I gotta do something
that's faster
I'm gonna take my EEP on okay I got this
I'm threatening a fork I should have
just develop my knight Knight c3 to
defend that pawn okay let's get some
development in queenside castle let's
just do that so I can with my knight
fish up here I guess mm-hmm my other
rook doing something actually Bishop
trade I want to trade this one right
down these Knights are a pain though
there's a knight check here I should
probably get out of that just in case
something bad happens I'm floundering
right now if you didn't realize lacking
good plan this should be the plan get
the knight out of your territory guard B
3 and E 2 inch your king up a little bit
get your knight in a better position now
can I have the rooks coming up these are
too tricky knight in here is my nice
very well placed though on this square
oh they won't have to do that move this
is giving up a really nice square I feel
like my opponent's playing much better
than they're rating rook takes rook I
take here first maybe oh they're
dropping the rook okay that was
definitely helpful they might be
resigning soon they're finding the
resign button they are they resigned in
that one whoa 51 51 30 25 okay let's
throw a knight in the center
let's grab some space with tempo that's
actually not space just yet development
with tempo I want to get my light square
Bishop out okay putting pressure on that
pun I'm okay with this transition if
Knight here and they had that structural
change Queen see somewhere Queen c7 on
h2 to give him a kick all right take
with my knight reinforce this guy
you might clean up right here let's
throw that night in a pin and see if
they weaken and they are weakening
themselves a little bit get on the open
file this square as well get my knight
in here not just yet next move Knight to
e3 is gonna be really strong they might
have to give the exchange they're gonna
get here though no no though I'm on the
knight and the rook they might have to
do f5 just to complicate their down on
time this pawn is pinned remember that
centralize I'm just gonna take care it's
very ugly but I think I could do that
rook check I didn't realize that they
moved that's not a good sign okay let's
just defend my king this Knight is
anchored right in there can't take I'm
in a pin just yet Queen to g5 still pile
up on this wow house right here fall for
Queen h7 it wouldn't be mate but let's
just stop that with the pawn now don't
move that pun they don't have any time
they're down on time back determined 61
30 28 27 I'm shooting for top three
forget about top one this is the guy
that's gonna kill you
alright let's try the Benoni alright he
flies and he's strong clearly let's see
if he could weather the storm here
throwing h-bond when in doubt okay this
is trouble that's trouble actually night
there huh let's get rid of that guy he's
never gonna allow it okay my scrub a
ship exchange not allowing that either
throw my knight in f4 okay I have some
dark square stuff that maybe I could put
to use we're gonna see hmm
rook act oh that's just a dead rook what
am i doing
bishop here you know what I don't want
my F pawn anymore that was a very good
move um I have to try and hold my dark
squares mmm I can't do it yeah that's a
strong move that's a strong move Oh rook
here you have to give stuff up they're
gonna they could have taken my bishop
why didn't they take my bishop they're
out for something more on their rook now
they're defending the rook they're gonna
do a pawn push let's get out of the line
of fire I don't have any time either
ouch pawn push happening soon yeah
everything's falling everything's
falling on this yeah but it's collapsing
completely no time no time pawn push in
do panchak oh look at the time no time
and they could actually just trade and
win with the rook check at the end Oh
down on time and position they had 11
seconds as well ouch okay let's continue
Sicilian ah I'm gonna go for that I
don't think there's compensation with
that one let's get in a six in d5 why
not why not
pawn takes like two recapture and I have
an open door for my bishop okay let's
get castled yeah I felt like I was on
the defensive the whole game I had a
lack of space and I didn't get anything
rolling there I tried something with the
dark squares it was not happening it
didn't bite didn't give up there dark
square bishop
I probably should have played f3 a
little bit sooner than that one let's
throw this one and enter their position
with tempo half opened file I don't want
to take that bishop just yet
B five maybe even c4 in to b3 one of
these when I could be a pest on either
these squares I think let's go here take
with the rook just so there's no tricks
against my queen and my queen here let's
just get this rook working b5 let's just
cover this my light squares are weakened
but they've given up their light square
bishop that's just know let's come over
here be a little bit more active a
little bit more active that is a fork
that was helpful
all right they're gonna trade oh okay
wait what oh oh my goodness I didn't
take their Queen back that was a mouse
lip uh-oh
no stop it oh that was a horrible Mouse
lip horrible
we know I did another mouth slip oh man
terrible down on time that's all I had
oh man there's only four minutes
remaining I have to somehow try and get
third seventy-three 39:34 Oh - Mouse
lips is too many
okay let's guard that night guard that
night
okay let's babysit that D floor phone up
to e1 we're gonna have mass exchanges on
e4 or are we how many more games can get
in let's take here and then let's do
that
that's they're gonna take that uh I
thought they might snip that a2 pond
move their night I get there light
square bishop they're taking some time
on this move okay they might miss that
their Queens hit no okay well it's a
fast move at least to get in there g5
and then double my Knights a monster
they're on c3 I should have maybe played
a four it's clamped down on the the
Queen side there I have this covered try
my bishop back and then play f4 f5 yeah
they're lacking a plan it's definitely
difficult I could even go in for h4 g5
while they're trying to do something I
am giving up this square but this was
the idea to break down their structure
I'm crashing through their bishops
pinned I could take you with check okay
and then I'm gonna give that give this
up just to break through and then push
my pawn to Victory Lane hopefully
Victory Lane mate soon maybe
next two minutes back to terminal or do
I stand 32 if I only get I think I need
to bruiser --k to try and overtake one
of these two guys
yeah let's preserve let me think twice
about this lunch and I berserk yeah I
somehow think I shouldn't preserve in
this against this one I don't know if
you agree or not let's preserve let's
definitely berserk against this run
because last time you had a your
opponent had 11 seconds on you like you
might not want to berserk and against
this guy just a thought
it's just a thought okay you're gonna
give me the c-4 square my knight could
be a beast on that square I think no
okay in a plant in here yeah I'm gonna
feel the pain very soon I know it let's
get a flight square while I'm getting
dizzy
I'm getting dizzy now my Queens having
to get out of pins and stuff mmm that
one's painful I got to mix it up let's
try that I can't I can't take that I
can't take that okay I'm actually a
little bit out of the woods but not on
the clock
I'm not out of the clock woods wise I
could've taken the Queen I could take
the last move oh my goodness
lucky duck but it's not over by any
means
oh man I'm under rook I'm on the rook
there's two pesky Knights around though
watch out for those pesky Knights you
need to get rid of one of them um let's
give a check here that's how you I
should just take in the night we're
gonna get some trades the Knights in the
pin I gotta go fast I was a bad premium
I think they resigned hmm well that was
a good end but ah tough tough tough the
first place
well worth it blur the point standings
they're at 8347 43 36 36 so even if I
won that it wasn't even close
alright what was at 8347 it was a race
for a second only between a handful
alright the Vandenberg arena
ah right I didn't preserve any 50%
berserk for first place guy 10% and then
20% for third all right 116 entered when
it started it was around I think 60 so
there were a lot of like joiners all
right here was the giant list that took
part in this actually let me see if I
can get it on the screen oh there's the
scroll thing right there there's two
different scrolling guys there we go
these are all who took part in it I
think you should be able to see it I
should probably scroll up just a little
bit more there we go just to see
everyone who took part in it and
everyone who maybe withdrew a hundred
and change entered this one a very nice
turnout and there we go alright to the
100 in change who took part in this I
see what is it what's the exact number
of the 116 of you good games let me post
that in there right here
games oh I think I got that right yep
alright Gigi's